we are all on the cringe made men by the
fringe
cringe no no
Malcolm's try not to cringe challenge
he's found my biggest weakness I get it
at least one three or four cringe
seizures every day
it's a condition I suffer from a long
time now I don't appreciate you making
fun of me for it now
I cringe harder than no man has ever
drenched my life
it's a cringe companies you couldn't
make me laugh
we'll see about the cringe they're not
blue now don't tell me that what he's
clearly a pet oh my god Oh God god
they're kids dude
he says she doesn't want to kiss you
she's uncomfortable she's on television
what the [ __ ] is no you can't use her to
stay in whispering you hear that Alison
in front of the camera he says that [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] oh yeah no that's just
good old Carl he kisses the kids he's so
what he does well I guess you can't win
the show then did he it she said he said
dirty old someone said dirty old man
don't kiss please oh my god
if that was my kid I would go up and
punch the [ __ ] out of him
where's this what is it laughter Joe
[Laughter]
[Applause]
deal with your problems oh my god what
the [ __ ] this is the reason why
colouring book our books are coming back
for adults [ __ ] Jesus Christ dude
that's that's depressing and hilarious
at the same time oh my god this is
horrible
I can't cringe man I can't cringe cringe
is my weakness you're not wearing much
in the downstairs department you mean I
have a small penis
no no anywhere you know I mean not
wearing much well I haven't got the
stocking yet god damn it Karen give me
the sock you were wearing I wasn't
wearing much okay no body butters that's
how much bigger it's gonna look smaller
guy I didn't see anything about me if
the Australian accent just made it so
much better buddy put us up so much
bigger it's gonna look smaller
buddy Bayless is so much bigger so it's
gonna look more there's so much more
left
go ahead
you did and I've got it's a big penis
god dammit I would say that was quite
charming and endearing and the cringe
level was not even peaking on level two
it was an embarrassing yes but there is
a difference cringe and embarrassing
different things next clip terrified by
your old car are you what first of all I
haven't in watched I've watched two
seconds why are car salesmen so [ __ ]
cringy do not fear John Lowe meet here
tragic Warrington this is like me if the
cringe is coming up this is like me when
I did my first youtube video and it's
still still pretty much spot on me
actually and I'm a dealer for the people
it was it [ __ ]
absolutely was it cringing just a little
bit but you can tell he's a dead he gets
the free pass you know where the [ __ ] is
this guy with the glasses where the [ __ ]
is this guy I don't I have a lot of
questions but cringe mm-hmm moving on oh
this is gonna be good
original music by ade and arrows music
video free download dark wave I already
love it
alright well it's got a pretty dope
bassline so far
[Music]
so that's a nice katana there on the
wall I can really appreciate a man with
a with a katana collection
[Music]
it keeps filming windows players blip is
feeling at ease you can't just add the
video in dude what the [ __ ] why would
you what happened there I want to know
this story what the [ __ ] just oh my god
Oh log it like your name is Shekhar oh
I'm not ready
[Music]
dude how many times you got to adjust
your hair dude like honestly I get it
I'll never be this happy that's why I'm
jealous I'm just a hater
all right don't listen to me if you did
take steroids yeah would you inject them
yeah every morning
I know it some guys but if I was to use
steroids I'd be a very mild user and I
have once would have if I had have ever
tried it I would have tried it once to
use a lot and and didn't really notice
the great deal of difference do you
oughta mean but a lot of women take
would take four to five times of the
amount that I take would take yeah would
take
ah see Louie is such a pro cuz I could
not talk to people like this like I
would just want to keep like I can't
talk to people like this
it doesn't work for me that's impressive
that's a talent like if dj khaled spoke
to me I don't know how to respond to
pure gibberish like what do you say I
don't get it I have so much surely I got
more drilling and it's having about the
jury cuz you know this is hard man but
I'm really enjoying it I'm not gonna lie
I enjoy the crazy Matt is some fresh
memes dude which year is this 2015
unforgiveable long cat is the [ __ ]
meme from like 2009 but I'm not gonna
finish this oh my god what the [ __ ] is
this I clicked a random frame a random
frame I do not set that up what the [ __ ]
is going on here
it's people like this that ruined the
great name of PewDiePie the [ __ ] do you
think I am full of memes how dare you
[Music]
[Applause]
I want this I want this I want this in
my funeral I really honestly do I'm
putting this out here right now this is
official when I die
play this [ __ ] on my funeral please this
date event a lot of people these days
talk about this genius because they
don't learn anything new my whole life
revolves around educating myself I said
what is about young people they're so
naive yeah you're vegan and you atheist
and you just discover the world and
everyone else is blind I leave at 7 a.m.
to go to a school that I started with me
and my sister where we learn is pretty
much like homeschooling but you start at
school but it's pretty much
homeschooling that's rich sister where
we learn is pretty much like
homeschooling but this guy needs to go
to school this guy needs someone to say
to his face dude you're a [ __ ] idiot
and he'll be like oh yeah okay finally
we have the ultimate cringe sign I swear
to [ __ ] god if it goes to the
PewDiePie channel
oh my god oh it goes to the PT that's
real funny you know alright press what
have we learned here today if you make
shitty content don't upload it to
YouTube
I am the worst person in the universe to
say that but anyway if you enjoyed this
video leave a like I hope you enjoyed I
had a lot of fun would love to do
another one of these let me know and as
always stay awesome rest I am a really
nice guy that would rather spend a night
cuddling than having sex I am a I am a I
am